vous prenez le relais de ceux qui sont
venus avant et vous l'avez porté aussi loin que
vous le pouvez, puis vous l'ajoutez
bien loin d'Honolulu principalement grandi
en Indonésie pendant un certain temps aussi vous un tout
autre type de frère vous vous rendez compte
que  d'accord ce n'est pas ma scène quelle est
ta scène
J'essaie toujours de comprendre ça
surprise maman oh ma parole tu sais que je suis la
seule personne noire dans quatre de mes cinq
cours oh tu es à moitié blanc aussi tu peux
t'intégrer n'importe où  je ne savais pas que le monde est une
grande place pour toi tu trouveras ton chemin
tu as une pièce d'identité je suis étudiant ici carte d'identité bien
je ne te vois pas je les considère alors
qu'est-ce qui est si spécial à propos de moi hein
alors comment  est-ce que le changement se produit, je crois aux
gens qui créent le hasard
maman du Kansas et mon père du
Kenya et vous savez ce que cela fait de vous,
donc je ne pense pas que cela vous rend américain vous
vous